[Music]
hi rob hello my name is sarah newman i'm
calling from minneapolis minnesota i was
so curious one of my favorite shows of
all time was the grinder and i can't
even tell you how disappointed i was
when it was not picked up for a second
season
the writing the delivery the chemistry
between you and fred savage i just i
thought it was electric so what i love
to learn is when
things like that happen how does rob
lowe process rejection and overcome to
learn lessons and move on
thank you so much for your podcast i am
absolutely loving it i can't get enough
of it
thanks for everything that you do i
appreciate your talent and i can't wait
to hear what you have to say
take care
wow sarah thank you so much for for that
i i so appreciate it and you're right
that was that like rocked my world
when the grinder didn't get picked up
because with all possible humility um i
have to say
i think the show's genius
i loved it
i would put the grinder up there with
any comedy ever made i really mean that
and i mean i'm not trying to be like an
egomaniac or anything i mean it's i just
loved the show i loved it
and
you know i have all these theories that
really it's a streaming show that should
have been on a streamer and if it had
been on netflix or hulu or
amazon or apple it would still be going
on today for sure it would
but it was a little too weird for
network but i do have total appreciation
that they put it on in the first place i
couldn't believe
that fox put it on to begin with
so i was really grateful that we got to
do 22 of them and we have 22 episodes
and
you know i'm a positive person but you
ask me how i deal with rejection i i
think it was wired that way to be a
glasses half full guy
so
my takeaway is we got to do it and there
are 22 of them and they're there forever
and you can watch them on hulu or you
can find them and they're not going
anywhere
um if we'd have made this show 10 years
ago
you wouldn't be able to find it but now
in the world that we live in things live
forever and when you make something bad
that's about rules but when you make
something good it's the good news and
and i love the grinder and if you
haven't seen it i highly recommend it it
is
and i love parks and recreation
obviously i do a podcast about it i love
it the grinder's my favorite comedy i've
ever been in period
so thank you for that and again
resilience dealing with rejection
everybody deals with it
and you know it doesn't matter who you
are
what you are
what your life circumstances is
everybody does everybody deals with
rejection
and part of the comfort is is knowing
that
and knowing that you know you're not
alone everybody has it the stakes may be
different in different people's lives
but it doesn't make it any easier
and um i think that having a positive
outlook and not
grousing about it not being a victim
there's a lot of victim stuff in the
culture i am not a fan
at all
i think that
to the extent that you take
responsibility for your own stuff good
and bad is to the extent that you're
empowered to move forward and if i sat
around and went the network screwed me
that was a great show and they canceled
it boo network then i would i would end
up being at the mercy of the network
but instead
i'm
empowering myself
by not doing that
so
that's sort of what i try to tell people
who ask me and tell my kids and i hope
that that made some sense thank you for
for calling in and thank you for
listening